a beloved mentally unstable masked
vigilante once said i'm not trapped in
here with you you're trapped in here
with me
and this exact sentiment was shared by
scp-682
the hard-to-destroy reptile as it
traversed the almost limitless liminal
hell known as the backrooms it'd been
little more than a standard chase and
secure mission for the mobile task
forces pursuing
scp-682 after its latest deadly
containment breach until the vicious
lizard made its way into an abandoned
warehouse and no clipped its way into a
new reality as the scp foundation are
still desperately searching for the
missing beast back in our native reality
682 has been discovering whole new
vistas of violence first it found itself
in the endless yellow halls of level
zero where if the madness doesn't get
you the starvation and thirst will well
unless you're an anomalous reptilian
abomination that can seemingly adapt to
any situation 160 to escape this gaudy
purgatory it found its way into level 1
an endless warehouse full of equal parts
monsters and hapless human settlers all
of whom it decimated in a single bloody
afternoon then on to level two the pipe
rooms where it faced a bevy of beasts
that it eagerly put into the ground and
that brings us up to now and by
extension on to level three
spilled out into another section of long
industrial hallways it didn't know how
it had gotten in and honestly it didn't
really care at this point all it needed
to do was keep moving forward and
killing as it pleased and it seemed
there were plenty of creatures down here
to kill
that being said this level had a certain
energy to it and we mean that literally
682 is incredibly sensitive well
senses allowed it to detect an
incredibly powerful electrical field
emanating from this level and from the
sounds of machines humming all around it
traveling down great bundles of wires
and pipes bound to the walls it knew
that this level must have been attached
to a generator of truly incredible size
it charged forward weaving around the
different hallways at freakish speeds
searching for the next thing it could
blast into oblivion and thankfully it
was able to find its first target soon
enough a nest of creatures known as
death moths these were huge fluttering
moths of freakish size congregating
around a glowing electrical outlet
intriguing
scp-682 decided to approach and
introduce itself after all they looked
like pretty easy prey 682 would regret
this oversight while the male death
moths are pretty much harmless the
female death moths have an extremely
potent defense mechanism as scp-682
approached the creatures began swarming
and spraying acid onto its reptilian
flesh this was painful and irritating
for 682 of course but if any entity on
earth is pretty accustomed to dealing
with large quantities of powerful acid
by now it's
scp-682 its skin quickly healed from the
acidic onslaught and it developed a
powerful counter adaption a long sticky
froglike tongue which it used to devour
the nest full of death moths and move
along to its next target it continued
exploring level three a number of
hallways were marked off with metal bars
another very familiar sight for scp-682
so for simplicity's sake it just kept
itself to the unobstructed paths that's
where it soon ran into another life form
standing around like a sitting duck in
one of the level's many anomalous
hallways it was just another human in a
similar outfit to all those major
explorer group weaklings it had
destroyed earlier strangely even when
scp-682 entered the hallway with it it
didn't seem to react properly it just
vacantly stared off into space stumbling
around awkwardly 682 bemused whipped
this random disoriented stranger in the
chest with its tail sending him sailing
into the nearby wall it was at this
point that something strange happened
the force of the strike caused the man's
clothes and also skin to disintegrate
leaving something entirely different
underneath
scp-682 had no idea what was going on
but i knew that it hated it this was its
first encounter with a creature known as
a skin stealer it would be natural for a
human being to be terrified of an
abomination like this an apex predator
like 682 on the other hand had barely
even found the skinstealer interesting
with a single stomp from its clawed
reptilian foot the creature was very
very dead and scp-682 continued its
journey through the bowels of level
three it found itself drawn to whatever
the source of all the energy was if it
even had one single source it was almost
as though the entire level was one
gigantic predator powering the rest of
the back rooms and if there was
electricity perhaps there were other
humans in here to kill
scp-682 liked that idea very much indeed
however while making its way down a
slightly wider hallway one that it had
previously believed was completely
uninhabited it was suddenly ambushed by
a group of mysterious attackers a number
of tall grey creatures with long clawing
arms and unclear facial features stepped
away from the wall these entities are
known as the dullers ambush predators
native to the back rooms they normally
run away from threats but considering
the number of them congregated in the
hall around
scp-682 perhaps they felt a little more
confident about taking down their prey
in a group but they'd made a grave
miscalculation it would not matter
whether there was one dollar or a
thousand dollars in the battle between
them and scp-682
they would always always always be the
prey but lucky for them while they
weren't aware of this immutable fact yet
scp-682 was more than happy to give them
a first-hand education while the dollars
tried their best to claw into scp-682's
thick leathery hide the creature decided
to employ a new ability it had stolen
from the female death moths several new
glands developed all over 682's body
each of which produced a fine mist of
highly concentrated acid soon enough the
dollars were howling in pain and melting
away into dull grey puddles on the
ground never to reconstitute again
that's what you get for trying to climb
up the food chain folks it never ends
well unless you're 682 that is after
disposing of the dollars which in 682's
own humble opinion had more than earned
that title by indeed being extremely
dull it decided to continue its search
for some of the power sources on this
level perhaps it could harness this
ability for its own benefit but it was
interrupted by what is frankly one of
the grossest enemies in all of the back
rooms the bursters and if even hearing
the name makes you feel a little sick
then you're correctly primed for what
you're about to encounter they're
humanoid creatures that walk around on
all fours with its back legs grotesquely
stretched out into the shape of a dog's
hind legs but that's nothing compared to
the burster's truly diabolical back knee
all over the creature's back you can see
huge calloused cysts that contain a
potent and noxious acid sure the acid is
only about as dangerous as the stuff
produced by female death moths but in
our humble opinion the method of acid
delivery is far more repulsive and that
makes bursters less desirable to
encounter a small group of them
skittered out of the darkness towards
scp-682
the hard to destroy reptile also found
them disgusting though now that we think
about it
scp-682 thinks all forms of life are
disgusting so we suppose that it's all
relative however when they began to
burst their backs in coat 682 in their
horrible pus they perhaps earned the
rarely given label of extra disgusting
from this living embodiment of reptilian
hate 682 quickly retaliated by clawing
the horrid creatures to death which i
think we can all agree is a good and
well deserving ending for the vile
little beasts we would have done the
same thing the next enemies that 682
encountered weren't nightmarish
creatures
but in fact were human beings stationed
in the major explorer group's base gamma
the third most important base in all of
the back rooms they were on high alert
after losing contact with base alpha
several days before having no idea that
everyone at that base had been
slaughtered by a cp682
a fate that if they weren't tremendously
lucky they would soon share but they had
little more than luck on their side this
time
scp-682 sighted the base on the end of a
long hallway there was even a person
standing at the other end of the hall
seemingly blissfully aware of the
encroaching presence of one of the scp
foundation's most dangerous and
formidable captives 682 loved killing
humans most of all they weren't just
dumb animals they had the intellectual
capacity to actually appreciate the life
that was being ripped away from them and
it made the whole act even more
pleasurable for scp-682
it set its sights on the ignorant major
explorer group member leaning against
the distant wall and decided to charge
for him clause extended and fangs
bearered this would be such easy prey
until the moment when someone in the
distance yelled now and the seemingly
defenseless human turned around and
pulled the lever on the wall suddenly
the whole hallway was electrified
sending millions of volts coursing
through scp-682 writhing body this whole
thing had been an elaborate trap the
humans at base gamma hadn't survived
this long in the back rooms by being
stupid the more technically savvy
members had rewired some of the hallways
to channel the immense energy of the
generators and fry any unfortunate
entities that tried to use these
hallways to break into base gamma there
was one big problem though
scp-682 wasn't just any unfortunate
entity while it did initially look like
electricity might fry the beast it
gradually began channeling the
electricity into its own body and
developing the capacity to re-gift this
electricity to the people who so kindly
provided it
scp-682 now a crackling conduit of
electricity leaped from the shocking
hallway and into base gamma soon enough
it had fatally electrocuted all 300
members of the major explorer group
posted in base gamma and returned to its
baseline state level 3 had grown
tiresome now it seemed that there were
no more exciting new creatures to
massacre as a result 682 slid into a
nearby elevator and went down where a
new level awaited this was how scp-682
got to level four and level four was not
what the hard to destroy reptile
expected in contrast to the industrial
nightmare of the previous few levels
level four was like a limitless office
block with all the furniture ripped out
while for some this might represent the
crushing existential banality of office
life and how the wheels of capitalism
inevitably work us all to death
scp-682 had never worked in an office
before so it didn't really have the
proper cultural reference points to
appreciate this more abstract kind of
fear it wanted monsters to kill 682
spent approximately six days searching
around the hellscape that is level 4 not
discovering a single person or entity
while it was there it was honestly the
most stressed that scp-682 had felt
since coming here the beast was almost
tempted to unscrew a light bulb from
above draw a little face on it begin
referring to it as wilson and then kill
it 682 felt the closest emotion it could
manage to immense gratitude when it
cited the glowing green of a distant
exit sign at the end of a long hallway
finally a way out onto another level
hopefully this one would have more
creatures to slaughter welcome
scp-682 to level 5.
scp-682 didn't really know what to
expect from the next level of the back
rooms after all it all seemed pretty
random so far but it definitely didn't
expect to see a classy well-appointed
hotel on the other end of the hallway
scp-682 had never seen the stanley
kubrick masterpiece the shining nor read
the book it was based on by master of
horror stephen king but if it had it
would probably have drawn the comparison
instead it was already busy tearing
through the ornate halls looking for new
prey to slaughter the first unexpected
encounter was with a small cat that
casually wandered out into the hallway
right in front of it the cat who didn't
seem threatened by scp-682 said hi i'm
samantha you got any meat you can lend
me i'll tell you your fortune if you do
scp-662 was frankly baffled it took a
moment to formulate a reply you
worthless creature you have no idea what
you're dealing with do you
i'm going to bring this place to ruin
and destroy all who reside within
682 said so ah no meat then 682 growled
and swiped at the cat with its claws
luckily she was able to dodge the cat
tutted and patted away into the darkness
muttering it'll bother the beast instead
jerk this piqued
scp-682's interest a beast to say
sounds important sounds powerful
finally a worthy opponent our battle
shall be legendary
and with renewed vigor as cp 632 began
prowling the halls of the back rooms
searching for this beast to defeat and
destroy but to begin with things were
grievously disappointing one of the
first monsters on this opulent hotel
level that the hard to destroy reptile
faced were diminutive little rodents
known as death rats which were
effectively slightly larger than normal
rats with little horns
scp-682 stomped them all with ease its
thoughts dripping with disdain for their
truly pathetic weakness what kind of
hotel allows itself to be filled with
rats even by human standards this would
be disgraceful
soon after scp-682 encountered a few
familiar foes female death moths and
hounds all as easy to kill as they were
before
scp-682 didn't understand the feline
promised that there was a beast down
here was it hiding from the mighty
reptile like a filthy coward
worthless but it was in the depths of
this cynicism that scp-682
encountered a growler first it heard the
sound of animalistic growling projected
directly into its mind getting louder
and louder by the moment then as the
growling grew in volume 682 heard the
thunderous footsteps of a huge quadruped
getting closer 632 wondered as the
roaring became almost deafening whether
this sounded heralded the approach of
the beast however the second the monster
actually turned the corner and came into
view 682 had to suppress the urge to
laugh it was one of the most absurd
things it had ever seen
it looked like a giant pile of pipe
cleaners in every color imaginable
arranged into a vaguely four-legged
structure this was the monster producing
all that psychic racket
pathetic
scp-682 resolved in that moment to show
the monster how it was done
scp-682 immediately evolved its own
psychic emission capacitors within its
brain and projected the message you are
a worthless little creature
directly into the simple mind of the
growler it began to quake in horror at
the booming of 682's voice in its brain
what was this terrifying new creature it
didn't understand and just like that 682
who had grown bored of this one-sided
psychic battle turned up the strength of
the psychic beam by a factor of 50. the
sudden psychic blast was so powerful
that the growler collapsed to the ground
and burst into flames burning itself
away into nothingness in a matter of
moments
just as weak as 682 had expected
hopefully the beast would provide a
greater challenge because this was just
getting sad
scp-682 shook off the disappointment and
continued running through the halls of
the hotel eventually after passing
through some dull dance hall called the
beverly room 682 found itself running
through a hallway full of long portraits
every person in the portraits had a
strange twisted grin on their face not
that this even registered to scp-682
what did occur to 682 though was the
figure that suddenly materialized in the
hallway in front of it it was a strange
figure to be sure an entity in a suit
with a large blue cuttlefish for a head
the creature cleared its throat and
began to speak well hello there you're
new here aren't you
such an interesting creature you've been
making some trouble on the other levels
haven't you
not that it's any of my business on the
contrary dear sir i like the cut of your
jib how would you feel about joining me
in the hotel business it isn't easy to
manage this dimension by myself after
all how about you and i come into my
office we can work out the terms of our
682 lunch forward and unceremoniously
devoured the creature's head allowing
its dapperly dress body to fall limply
to the ground dead
scp-682 grunted annoyed by the
distraction the creature had provided it
had better things to do
this beast has got to be around here
somewhere
want to learn more about the back rooms
check out our new sister channel the
back rooms explained where we're
exploring the back rooms level by level
and uncovering all of its secrets now go
check out scp-682 waze scp foundation
try to kill hard to destroy reptile and
scp-682 vs scp foundation hard to
destroy reptile termination attempts for
more of everyone's favorite ornery
reptile